virginia duffray says prince andrew
sexually abused her when she was 17
claims he's always denied but in a
dramatic development to these
long-running allegations her lawyers say
they have now served him with legal
papers after filing a civil suit against
him last month
mr frey says she was a victim of the
convicted pedophile jeffrey epstein and
she says she was made to have sex with
prince andrew on multiple occasions
for her case to proceed papers must be
delivered to the defendant according to
a court document filed in new york that
happened two weeks ago
it says her team left them with a police
officer at windsor's royal lodge that
means that it's game on for the lawsuit
it goes forward that means that after a
couple of weeks pass
her attorneys will be able to subpoena
records documents log books calendars
photos texts emails
anything that he or anybody else may
have that would become relevant to the
lawsuit and then i would have prince
andrew come in and give a deposition
which means under oath he has to finally
answer the questions that have been
dogging him for a long time
the court document states a first
attempt to serve the papers on the
prince was made on august 26th security
staff are reported to have said they'd
been told not to accept service of any
court process
a second attempt was made the next day
when the papers were left with a police
officer who said they'd been forwarded
to the legal team
the prince is currently at balmoral
where he's staying with the queen
sources close to him say he hasn't been
served in person and couldn't confirm if
security had received the documents
according to the court documents he has
until september 17th to respond
ishazarhid sky news